[Music]
thank you
imagine you're the owner of a small
software development firm and you want
to scale your business up
however a small team size the
unpredictability of demand and limited
resources are roadblocks for this
expansion that's when you hear about
cloud computing but before investing
money into it you decide to draw up the
differences between on-premise and
cloud-based Computing to make a better
decision when it comes to scalability
you pay more for an on-premise setup and
get lesser options too
once you've scaled up it is difficult to
scale down
and often leads to heavy losses in terms
of infrastructure and maintenance costs
cloud computing on the other hand allows
you to pay only for how much you use
with much easier and faster Provisions
for scaling up or down
next let's talk about server storage
on-premise systems need a lot of space
for their servers notwithstanding the
power and maintenance hassles that come
with them on the other hand cloud
computing Solutions are offered by cloud
service providers who manage and
maintain the servers saving you both
money and space then we have data
security on-premise systems offer less
data security thanks to a complicated
combination of physical and traditional
I.T security measures whereas cloud
computing systems offer much better
security and lets you avoid having to
constantly Monitor and manage security
protocols in the event that a data loss
does occur the chance for data recovery
with on-premise setups are very small in
contrast cloud computing systems have
robust disaster recovery measures in
place to ensure faster and easier data
recovery
finally we have maintenance on-premises
systems also require additional teams
for hardware and software maintenance
loading up the costs by a considerable
degree
cloud computing systems on the other
hand are maintained by the cloud service
providers reducing your costs and
resource allocation substantially
so now thinking that cloud computing is
a better option you decide to take a
closer look at what exactly cloud
computing is
cloud computing refers to the delivery
of on-demand Computing Services over the
internet on a pay-as-you-go basis in
simpler words rather than managing files
and services on a local storage device
you'll be doing the same over the
internet in a cost-efficient manner
cloud computing has two types of models
deployment model and service model
there are three types of deployment
models public private and hybrid Cloud
imagine you're traveling to work you've
got three options to choose from one you
have buses which represent public clouds
in this case the cloud infrastructure is
available to the public over the
internet
these are owned by cloud service
providers
two then you have the option of using
your own car this represents the private
cloud with the private Cloud the cloud
infrastructure is exclusively operated
by a single organization this can be
managed by the organization or a third
party and finally you have the option to
Hell a cap this represents the hybrid
cloud
hybrid cloud is a combination of the
functionalities of both public and
private clouds
next let's have a look at the service
models there are three major service
models available es pass and SAS
compared to on-premise models where
you'll need to manage and maintain every
component including applications data
virtualization and middleware cloud
computing service models are hassle free
is refers to infrastructure as a service
it is a cloud service model where users
get access to basic Computing
infrastructure they are commonly used by
it administrators if your organization
requires resources like storage or
virtual machines is the model for you
you only have to manage the data runtime
middleware applications and the OS while
the rest is handled by the cloud
providers next we have pass
pass or platform as a service provides
Cloud platforms and runtime environments
for developing testing and managing
applications this service model enables
users to deploy applications without the
need to acquire manage and maintain the
related architecture
if your organization is in need of a
platform for creating software
applications pass is the model for you
pass only requires you to handle the
applications and the data the rest of
the components like runtime middleware
operating systems servers storage and
others are handled by the cloud service
providers and finally we have SAS SAS or
software as a service involves cloud
services for hosting and managing your
software applications
software and Hardware requirements are
satisfied by the vendors so you don't
have to manage any of those aspects of
the solution if you'd rather not worry
about the hassles of owning any it
equipment the SAS model would be the one
to go with
SAS the cloud service provider handles
all components of the solution required
by the organization
time for a quiz now in which of the
following deployment models are you as
the business responsible for the
application data and operating system
one is
2. pass 3. SAS 4. is and pass let us
know your answer in the comments section
below
coming back to cloud computing some of
the most popular Cloud Computing
Services in the market are AWS or Amazon
web services Microsoft Azure and Google
Cloud platform want to learn more about
them and how they differ from each other
click on the top right corner for an
analysis of how these service platforms
are different from each other we hope
you found this informative and helpful
[Music]
right from the start software
development comprise two different
departments the development team that
develops the plan designs and builds the
system from scratch and the operation
team for testing and implementation of
whatever is developed the operations
team gave the development team feedback
on any bugs that needed fixing and any
rework required invariably the
development team would be idle awaiting
feedback from the operations team this
undoubtedly extended timelines and
delayed the entire software development
cycle there would be instances where the
development team moves on to the next
project while the operations team
continues to provide feedback for the
previous code this meant weeks or even
months for the project to be closed and
final code to be developed now what if
the two departments came together and
worked in collaboration with each other
what if the wall of confusion was broken
and this is called the devops approach
the devops symbol resembles an infinity
sign suggesting that it is a continuous
process of improving efficiency and
constant activity the devops approach
makes companies adapt faster to updates
and development changes the teams can
now deliver quickly and the deployments
are more consistent and smooth though
there may be communication challenges
devops manages a streamlined flow
between the teams and makes the software
development process successful the
devops culture is implemented in several
phases with the help of several tools
let's have a look at these faces
the first phase is the planning phase
where the development team puts down a
plan keeping in mind the application
objectives that are to be delivered to
the customer
once the plan is made the coding Begins
the development team works on the same
code and different versions of the code
are stored into a repository with the
help of tools like git and merged when
required this process is called Version
Control the code is then made executable
with tools like Maven and Gradle in the
build stage
after the code is successfully built it
is then tested for any bugs or errors
the most popular tool for automation
testing is selenium
once the code is passed several manual
and automated tests we can say that it
is ready for deployment and is sent to
the operations team
the operations team now deploys the code
to the working environment the most
prominent tools used to automate these
phases are ansible dockered and
kubernetes
after the deployment the product is
continuously monitored and nagios is one
of the top tools used to automate this
phase the feedback received after this
phase is sent back to the planning phase
and this is what forms the core of the
devops lifecycle that is the integration
phase Jenkins is the tool that sends the
code for building and testing if the
code passes the test it is sent for
deployment and this is referred to as
continuous integration there are many
Tech Giants and organizations that have
opted for the devops approach for
example Amazon Netflix Walmart Facebook
and Adobe Netflix introduced its online
streaming service in 2007. in 2014 it
was estimated that a downtime for about
an hour would cost Netflix two hundred
thousand dollars however now Netflix can
cope with such issues they opted for
devops in the most fantastic way Netflix
developed a tool called the Simeon Army
that continuously created bugs in the
environment without affecting the users
this chaos motivated the developers to
build a system that does not fall apart
when any such thing happens
so on this note here is a quiz for you
match the devops tool with the face it
is used in a
B
C
d none of the above
today more and more companies lean
towards automation with the aim of
reducing its delivery time and the gap
between its development and operations
teams to attain all of these there's
just one Gateway devops
and if you are also looking forward to
doing the same and Excel in devops check
out Simply learn's postgraduate program
in devops design in collaboration with
Caltech ctme the program can help you
master several in-demand devops skills
and tools like continuous integration
and delivery devops unCloud kubernetes
Docker and much more we hope you enjoyed
this video if you did a thumbs up would
be really appreciated here's your
reminder to subscribe to our Channel and
to click on the Bell icon for more on
the latest Technologies in trance thank
you for watching and stay tuned for more
from Simply learn